so how do we
design an iq test for machines
and intelligent tests for machines all
right so
in the paper outline a number of
requirements
that you expect of such a test and in
particular we should
start by acknowledging the priors
that we expect to be required in order
to perform the test
so we should be explicit about the
priors right
and if the goal is to compare machine
intelligence and human intelligence then
we should assume
human cognitive bias right and
secondly we should make sure that we are
testing
for skilled acquisition ability skill
acquisition efficiency in particular and
not for skill itself
meaning that every task featured in your
test should be
novel and should not be something that
you can anticipate
so for instance it should not be
possible to
brute force the space of possible
questions right
to pre-generate every possible question
and the answer
so it should be tasks that cannot be
anticipated
not just by the system itself but by the
creators
of the system right yeah you know what's
fascinating
i mean one of my favorite aspects of the
paper
and the work you do with the arc
challenge is um
the the process of making priors
explicit
just even that act alone as a really
powerful one
of like what are it's a it's a really
powerful question ask of us humans what
are the priors that we bring to the
table
so the the next step is like once you
have those priors how do you use them to
uh solve a novel task but like just even
making the prize explicit
is a really difficult and really
powerful step
and that that's like visually beautiful
and conceptually philosophically
beautiful part of
the work you did with uh and i guess
continue to do uh probably with the with
the paper and the arc challenge
can you talk about some of the priors
that we're talking about here
yes so a researcher has done a lot of
work on
what exactly uh um on the knowledge
priors that
that are innate uh to humans is
elizabeth
spelkie from harvard uh so
she developed the core knowledge uh
theory
which uh outlines four different
core knowledge systems uh so systems of
knowledge that we are
basically either born with or that we
are
hardwired to acquire very early on
in our development and there's no uh
there's no strong
um distinction between the two like if
you are
primed to acquire as a
certain type of knowledge uh in just a
few weeks you might as well
just be born with it it's just it's just
part of who you are
and so there are there are four
different core knowledge systems like
the first one
is the notion of objectness and
a basic physics like you recognize that
um something that moves uh currently for
instance is an object
so we intuitively naturally innately
divide the world into objects based on
this notion of
clearance physical currents and in terms
of elementary physics there's the
the fact that uh you know objects
can bump uh against each other
and the fact that they can occlude each
other so these are
things that we are essentially born with
or at least that we are
going to be acquiring extremely uh early
because really
hard wire to acquire them so a bunch of
points
pixels that move together on
objects that's part of the same object
yes
i mean i mean that
like i don't smoke weed but
if i did that's something i could sit
like all night and just like think about
i remember when i put in your paper just
object-ness i wasn't self-aware
i guess of how that particular prior
that that's such a fascinating prior
mm-hmm that like
and that's that's the most basic one but
yes just identity i
uh just yeah object yes it's it's very
basic i suppose but
it's so fundamental is this fundamental
human cognition
yeah and uh the second prior that's also
fundamental is
agent-ness which is not a real world a
real world but
so agentness the fact that some of these
objects
that you that you segment your
environment into
some of these objects are agents so
what's an agent
it's uh basically it's an object that
has
goals um so first that has goals
this this capable of per single so for
instance if you see
two dots uh moving in in a
roughly synchronized fashion you will
intuitively
infer that one of the dots is pursuing
the other so
that one of the dots is uh and
and one of the dots is an agent and its
goal is to avoid the other dart and one
of the dots the other dot
is also an asian and its goal is to
catch
the first start belkey has shown that
babies you know as young as three months
identify
uh agentness and goal directedness
in their environment another prior is a
basic
uh you know geometry and topology uh
like the notion of distance
the ability to uh navigate uh in your
environment and so on this is something
that is fundamentally
hardwired uh into our brain
it's in fact backed by very specific
neural mechanisms
like for instance grid cells and plate
cells
so it's it's something that's literally
hard coded
at the at the new level uh you know
in a hyper campus and the last prior
would be the notion of numbers like
numbers are not actually cultural
constructs
we are intuitively innately able
to do some basic counting and to compare
quantities
uh so it doesn't mean we can do
arbitrary arithmetic
uh uh counting the actual accounting
that's counting like counting one two
three
h then maybe more than three you can
also compare quantities if i give you
uh three dots and five dots you can tell
the the
the side with five dots there's more
darts uh so this is actually
an innate uh prior um so
that said the list may not be exhaustive
uh
so spelke is still uh uh you know
pursuing
uh uh the the potential existence of new
knowledge systems for instance
uh knowledge systems that we deal with
social
uh relationships yeah yeah i mean
and that could be which is which is much
much less relevant
uh uh to something like arc or iq
testing
right that could be stuff that's uh like
like you said rotation symmetry is
really interesting
it's very likely that there is uh
speaking about rotation that there is
uh in the brain a hard-coded system that
is capable of performing rotations
uh one one famous experiment uh that
people did in the
uh i don't remember uh who it was
exactly but in the
in the 70s uh was that
people found that if you asked people if
you give them
two different shapes and one of the
shapes
is a rotated version of the first shape
and you ask them
is is that shape a related version of
first strip or not
what you see is that the time it takes
people to answer
is linearly proportional right
to the angle of rotation so it's almost
like you have it somewhere in your brain
like a turntable um with a fixed speed
and if you want to know if two two
objects uh
uh are rotated version of each other you
put the object on the turntable
you let it move around a little bit and
then you and then you stop when you have
a match
and and that's really interesting so
what's the arc challenge
so in in the paper outline you know
all these principles that a good test of
machine intelligence and humanitarian
should follow
and the arc challenge is one attempt
to embody as many of these principles as
possible
so i don't think it's it's anywhere near
a perfect attempt
right it does not actually follow every
principle but
it is uh what i was able to do given the
given the constraints
so the format of arc is very similar to
classic iq tests in particular ravens
progressive mattresses
ravens yeah raven's privacy mattresses i
mean if
if you've done like you test in the past
you know where that is probably at least
you've seen it even if you don't know
what it's called
and so um you have a set of uh
tasks that's what they're called and for
each task you have
um training data which is a set of
inputs and output pairs so i uh
an input or output pair is a grid of
colors
basically the grid the size of the
grades these variables
is the size of the grid uh is variable
and um you're given an input
and you must transform it into the
proper outputs
right and so you're shown a few
demonstrations
of a task in the form of existing input
output pairs and then you're given a new
input
and you must provide you must produce
the correct output and
the assumptions
in arc is that every task should
only require
core knowledge priors should not require
any
outside knowledge so for instance uh
no language no english nothing like this
new concepts taken from
all human experience like trees dogs
cats and so on
so only tasks that are
reasoning tasks that are built on top of
a core knowledge priors
and some of the tasks are actually
explicitly trying to probe
specific forms of abstraction right
part of the reason why i wanted to
create arc
is i'm a big believer in
you know when you're faced with
a a problem as murky
as understanding how to autonomously
generate abstraction
in a machine you have to co-evolve the
solution
and the problem and so part of the
reason why i design act was to
clarify my ideas about the nature of
abstraction
right and some of the tasks are actually
designed to
to probe bits of that theory and there
are things that
are turned out to be very easy for
humans to perform including
young kids right but turn out to be
near impossible for machines so whatever
you learn from the nature of abstraction
from from designing that
like what can you clarify what you mean
one of the things you wanted to try to
understand
was this idea of abstraction
yes so clarifying uh my own ideas about
abstraction by
forcing myself to produce tasks that
would require
uh the ability to produce that form of
abstraction in order to solve them
got it okay so and by the way just uh i
mean people should check out i'll
probably overlay if you're watching the
video part but the
the grid input output
with the different colors on the grid
that's it that's i mean it's a very
simple world
but it's kind of beautiful it's it's
very similar to classic acutes like it's
not very original in that sense the main
difference with iq tests is that
we make the priors explicit which is not
usually the case in iq test
so you make it explicit that everything
should only be built
on top of core knowledge priors i also
think it's generally
more more diverse than iq tests in
general
uh and it's it perhaps requires a bit
more manual work to produce solutions
because you have to
to click around on a grid for a while
sometimes the grades can be as large as
30 by 30 cells
so how did you come up if you can
reveal with the questions like what's
the process of the questions was it
mostly you
yeah that came up with the questions
what uh how difficult is it to come up
with a question
like is this um scalable
to a much larger number if you think you
know with iq tests you might not
not necessarily want to or need it to be
scalable
with machines it's possible you
could argue that it needs to be scalable
so there are now a thousand questions
uh a thousand tasks yes wow including
the test and the private test set
i think it's fairly difficult in the
sense that a big requirement
is that every task should be uh novel
uh and unique and unpredictable right
like you don't want to create your your
own little world
that is uh simple enough that it would
be possible for a human
to reverse and generate and write down
an algorithm that could generate every
possible arc task and their solutions
for instance that we completely
invalidate the tests so
you're constantly coming up on new stuff
you need yeah you need a source
of novelty of uh
unfakable novelty and one thing i found
is that
as a human uh you are not a very good
source
of uh unthinkable novelty and so you
have to
pace the creation of these tasks quite a
bit there are only so many
unique tasks that you can do in a given
day
so that means coming up with truly
original new ideas
um did uh psychedelics help you at all
but i mean that's fascinating to think
about like so you would be like
walking or something like that are you
constantly thinking of
something totally new yes
i mean this is hard this is yeah i i
mean
i i'm not saying you've done anywhere
near perfect job at it
there is some amount of redundancy and
there are many imperfections
in ark so that said you should you
should consider ark as a work in
progress
it is not the definitive
uh where where the arc tasks today are
not
definitive states of the test i want to
keep refining it
um in the future i also think uh it
should be possible to open up the
creation of tasks
to broad audience to do crowdsourcing
that would involve several levels of
filtering obviously
but i think it's possible to apply
crowdsourcing to to develop a much
bigger and much more diverse arc data
set
that would also be free of potentially
you know some of
my own personal biases but is there
always need to be
a part of arc that's uh the test like
is hidden yes absolutely it is in
impressive that
uh the test set that you're using to
actually
benchmark algorithms is not accessible
to the people developing these
algorithms
because otherwise what's going to happen
is that the human engineers are just
going to solve the tasks
themselves and and encode their solution
in program form
but that again what you're seeing here
is
the process of intelligence happening in
the mind of the human and
and then you're just capturing its
crystallized output but that
crystallized output
is not the same thing as the process it
generated that's right it's not
intelligent in itself so what uh
by the way the idea of crowdsourcing it
is fascinating
i think i think the creation of
questions
is really exciting for people i think i
think there's a lot of really brilliant
people out there that love to create
these kinds of stuff
yeah one thing that that kind of
surprised me that i wasn't expecting is
that
lots of people seem to actually enjoy
arc
as a kind of game and i was really
seeing it as
as a test as a benchmark
of a fluid general intelligence
and lots of people just including kids
just started you know enjoying it as a
game so i think that's that's
encouraging
yeah i'm i'm fascinated by there's a
world of people who create iq questions
i think i think that's a cool
uh it's a cool activity for machines
that for humans and people
humans are themselves fascinated by
taking the questions like
you know measuring their own
intelligence
i mean that's just really compelling
it's really interesting to me too it
helps
one of the cool things about arc you
said it's kind of uh inspired by iq
tests or whatever follows a similar
process but because of its nature
because of the context in which it lives
it immediately forces you to think about
the nature of intelligence as opposed to
just a test of your own like it forces
you to really think this i don't know
if it's if it's within the question
inherent in the question or just the
fact that it lives
in a test that's supposed to be a test
of machine intelligence absolutely as
you
as you solve arc tasks as a human
you will be forced to basically
introspect
yeah you how you come up with solutions
and that forces you to reflect
on uh the human problem solving process
and the way your own mind generates
uh abstract representations
of the problems uh it's exposed to
uh i i think it's due to the fact that
the set of core knowledge priors uh that
arc is built upon is so small
it's all a recombination of a very very
uh small set um of assumptions
okay so what's the future of ark so you
you held arc as a challenge as part of
like a kegel competition
yes kaggle competition and
what do you think do you think that's
something that continues for
five years ten years like just continues
growing yes absolutely
so arc itself will keep evolving so i've
talked about crowdsourcing i think
that's uh that's a
good avenue uh another thing i'm
starting is
i'll be collaborating with folks uh from
the psychology department at nyu life
uh to do human testing uh on arc and
i think there are lots of interesting
questions you can start asking
especially as you
start correlating um machine solutions
to arc tasks and uh and
the human characteristics of solutions
like for instance you can
try to see if there's a a relationship
between the
human perceived difficulty if a task uh
and the machine person yes and and
exactly some measure of machine
perceived
nice big playground in which to explore
this very difference
it's the same thing as we talked about
the autonomous vehicles the things that
could be difficult for humans might be
very different than the things that yes
absolutely and formalizing or making
explicit
that difference and difficulty will
teach us something may teach us
something fundamental about intelligence
so one thing i think we did well uh with
arc
is that it's proving to be a very
uh actionable tests in the sense that
uh machine performance and arcs started
at very much
zero initially uh while you know
humans found actually the tasks very
easy
and that that alone was like a
big red flashing light saying that
something is going on
and that we are missing something and at
the same time
uh machine performance did not stay at
zero for very long actually within two
weeks of the carroll competition we
started having
a non-zero number and now the state of
the art is around
uh 20 of the test set uh solved
and so arc is actually a challenge where
our capabilities start at zero which
indicates the need for progress
but it's also not an impossible
challenge it's not accessible you can
start making progress
uh basically right away at the same time
we are still very far from having solved
it and that's actually
a very positive outcome of the
competition is that the competition has
has proven that uh there was
no obvious shortcut to solve these tasks
right yeah so the test held up
yeah exactly that was the primary reason
to do the cargo competition is to check
if some some you know clever person was
going to
hack the benchmark and that did not
happen
right like people who are solving the
tasks are essentially doing it
uh uh well in a way they're they're
they're actually exploring some flaws
of art that we will need to address in
the future especially they're
essentially anticipating what sort of uh
tasks may be containing the test sets
right right um which is this kind of
yeah that's the kind of hacking it's
it's human hacking of the test yes that
that said you know uh
with the state of the art it's like uh
20 percent we're still
very very far uh from even level which
is closer to 200 percent
and so and i i do believe that you know
it will
it will take a while uh until
we reach a human parity
on arc and that by the time we have
human parity
we will have ai systems that are
probably pretty close to human level
in terms of general fluid intelligence
which is
i mean it's they're not going to be
necessarily human-like they're not
necessarily
uh you would not necessarily recognize
them as you know being an egi
but they would be capable of a degree of
generalization that matches the
generalization
performed by human food intelligence
you